what up space fam goes in here for anime
outpouring today I'm going to be
counting down the five best fights and
Demon Slayer in my view Before we jump
into it I want to give a quick thank you
to the seven deadly sins grand cross
mobile game for sponsoring this video
the hit game from Japan is finally
getting a global release in English and
I've had the pleasure of playing it
before the official global release the
seven deadly sins grand cross mobile
game is an absolute blast for every
seven deadly sins fan it includes
awesome graphics a unique card based
battle system and it allows you to
faithfully relive the events of the
anime while actually having control of
your favorite characters in battle the
battles are a lot of fun depending on
which characters you choose to be on
your team you can unlock special attacks
which combine their powers into unique
combo moves you can even include the
mighty Lord Twigg o on your team which
let's face it makes you basically
unstoppable check the game out for
yourself by clicking the link down in
the description below
the game features beautiful seven deadly
sins music and the original of Japanese
voice actors reprise their roles as our
favorite sins relive the magic of the
story engage an epic combat in both
co-op and PvP modes and unlock cool
features like original game exclusive
outfits and costumes for your favorite
characters just click the link down in
the description to download the game and
begin your journey it's free to play on
Android and iOS now in regards to fights
the quality of a fight can be judged by
many different factors including how
strong the fighters are the emotional
impact of the fight the story behind the
fight as well as the strategy used to
win the fight and so on anime or manga
fights truly are their own art form and
I'm very excited to break down some of
the best fights in one of my favorite
series if you enjoy seeing the unit
videos on this channel and you want to
keep them coming make sure to smash that
like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
it's a notification battle where you'll
miss future it even say your videos
there will be manga spoilers in this
video most of these fights have not been
animated yet so you've been warned the
battles can be from manga but they have
to be finished so we can view them as a
whole
thus I won't be talking about ongoing
fights that have yet to finish no matter
how apik they may be don't worry I'll
probably dedicate a whole video to this
ongoing final fight once it is wrapped
up now let's jump into number five
number five is the fight against yuuichi
and moves on this fight was very short
but it was one of the most memorable
because of who was fighting you Ichi is
considered to be the strongest even seer
in history and the strongest character
in the entire series he created the
first and strongest breath style the
breath of the Sun and we get to see this
legend take on the main antagonist of
the series moves on the first and
strongest demon since the beginning of
the series moves on has loomed over the
story he's presented initially as a
ridiculously powerful demon that no one
can beat even his underlings the upper
moons have lived for centuries and
killed many pillars for this reason this
fight is amazing because the image we
have a moose on is completely flipped
moves on starts out confident as usual
but the strongest human proves to be too
much for the strongest demon your deechi
sense that even a single scratch by
Mouzon could kill him
so he was extremely careful for the
first time you'd Ichi felt a chill down
his spine this builds the hype because
you're Ichi is so talented
he's usually bored with fighting during
this fight your ichi completed his
legendary sword forms moves on was
confused because his body wasn't
regenerating your DG's bright red blade
was super effective against the
progenitor of demons your ichi was about
to finish off moves on when moves ons
body burst open into 1800 pieces of
flesh your Ichi being the mad lad he is
managed to cut more than 1500 but enough
escape 4 moves on to regenerate it was a
short lead fight but it was enough for
moose on to get PTSD from the encounter
even in Pancho's lifetime Mulan still
has flashbacks of your Ichi that's how
much your reach is skilled traumatized
him in terms of power yo Deecee is more
monstrous than any demon your Ichi
turned a big bad villain of the series
who is usually hunting down humans into
his prey when confronted with your Ichi
moves on the demon king of pop ran away
like a coward he was completely helpless
and after that Muslim spent the rest of
his life avoiding your Ichi this fight
is great because we get to see the
strongest fighters and demons there go
at it we get to see the strongest
character in the series go full-out and
fight in a battle that actually sends a
chill down his spine the battle is
amazing in and of itself but it is also
very important for the rest of the story
poncho your Ichi successor is now trying
to finish what you're eg started during
this fight you're Ichi free Tamayo
from Musa as grass and if you're caught
up you know that Tom AO was instrumental
in the final fight against Mouzon you're
Ichi couldn't finish off moves on in
this battle but he set the stage so that
the final battle we are experiencing now
in the manga could take place it is very
possible that the series will end
without us ever seeing a stronger
character than your Ichi fight so this
might go down as the fight that
showcased the highest caliber of skill
in the entire series as we know strong
opponents aren't the only way to judge a
fight accordingly next we have a fight
among much weaker characters but it was
delivered so well that I have to include
it here in 4th place I have the fight
against lower Moon v the Rui in this
case I'm going to be referring to the
anime which over-delivered on the hype
and awesomeness of this fight this fight
has to be super excited to see some of
the other fights on this list animated
this was the best choreographed and
beautiful fight I saw in 2019 ninja the
famous video game streamer even tweeted
to his millions of followers that Demon
Slayer might be his favorite anime of
all time after this that's the kind of
impact one amazing fight can have on
someone one vid on youtube showing
tantrum and a Zuko working together
against threwi has almost eleven and a
half million views none of this
surprises me though because I also
experienced the hype when I watched this
battle I was on the edge of my seat the
emotions were overflowing Tonto use
advance of the fire-god an epic new
breathing style and nez Zuko used her
blood demon art for the first time they
work together to get through his head
off of his body and the music voice
acting and breathtaking visuals came
together perfectly
during the next episode we find out that
it Rui took his own head before they
could cut it but this didn't take away
from the epicness of the previous
episode and to boot we got to see GU
shine he came in the nick of time saved
hunter from near death and then
absolutely wrecked Rui Rui launched his
strongest attacks at him and Gil you
used that calm to stop them without
moving he then just walked up to women
cut off his head like it was nothing Rui
was built up so much that an upgraded
tundra and as ago working together
couldn't beat him and
you comes in and just flexes on him I
love this part and I want to show how
strong the pillars are and how much more
Tundra had to grow at the time from
start to finish
I love the fight against truely and the
animated version was easily one of my
favorite anime moments of 2019 next I
want to talk about the fight against
upper moon three Akasa that's right in
third place we have upper moon three I
may behold video about how a Kazaa was
the best villain in Demon Slayer and I
made that decision after this fight you
could say that this fight started when
Alcazar first fought that I'm Goku and
ended after Tundra beat him
yes it's technically two different
fights and I'm going to be focusing on
the latter primarily but you must look
at the ren goku vs off as a fight to
fully appreciate the time join gear
versus arc as a fight then goku is
easily one of my favourite characters in
the entire series at the time when he
fought a cassandra in oscar and sonny -
were too weak to help if they tried they
would have just gotten in the way
then goku died during that battle but he
arguably won at the same time his goal
was to protect everyone else from Icaza
and he succeeded in doing that what's
more a cos I ran away before I ran Goku
was fully dead in order to avoid the Sun
Alcazar and like a coward before the
match was fully over even though the
demon slayers like rain Goku are always
willing to fight them during the
nighttime when the demons have the clear
advantage Icaza lived and then Goku died
but and Goku was so great in this fight
that he really felt like the winner and
he even went on to become one of my
favorite anime characters after it so
why would I make a whole video about how
akasa is my favorite villain after he
killed one of my favorite anime
characters well it's because his fight
against GU and tan judo man just to do
the impossible it manages to turn him
from one of the most hated characters to
one of the most likable let's jump to
the fight and see exactly how the manga
accomplishes this extremely impressive
feat Laza starts off wrecking time
showing you he talks about how weaklings
make him sick and how nothing other than
the law nature weeds them out he even
talks about how he hates our lovable
protagonists again he's doing a good job
of being hateable right here Octus
ascends gu flying near the beginning and
then the water pillar comes back with an
awakened demon ser mark yet even though
he's stronger than when he absolutely
embarrassed through he without
he's no match for a casa our Casa breaks
view sword by punching it give you a
swordsmanship expert brought a sword to
a fistfight in autism broke it with a
punch that must be one of the biggest
flexes in anime then we see tangelos non
self state which fascinates me he uses
it to save you from getting killed by
Icaza in a way dungeon or redeems
himself for not being able to save in
goku by saving GU the complete
transformation of tundra from a helpless
nuisance to someone who scares Icaza is
amazing Octus unleashes his final form
attack and use dead calm is useless
against it he gets hit with a hundred
blows all at once Tantra used the
see-through world and his selfless state
to help him dodge so he's pretty much
unfazed he could catch akka sawed off
guard but he chooses to taka so that
he's going to cut off his head before he
does
aw Jesus sees he's coming but tundra is
too quick and he succeeds in cutting off
his head
when animated this will no doubt be an
absolutely glorious moment even without
a head though Casas keeps kicking butt
he hits ton zero so hard he passes out
EU hits him with everything he's got but
he quickly regenerates even without a
head after this we see Alka sauce past
memories and these memories make us view
him in a completely different light as
we know from Naruto fights can be way
more impactful when combined with past
memories and the Arkansas fight shows
this technique being used at its best in
his human life akiza grew up with a sick
father the medicine was too expensive
and he had to steal in order to afford
it as a result he was marked as a
criminal and beaten his father hung
himself so that our cousin would stop
committing crimes but that's the last
thing I cuz I wanted his father wasn't a
burden on him at all he was pretty much
his only reason for living the only joy
in his life he kept taking out his
frustration on people until a cheery guy
knocked him out
this guy had a sick daughter and took a
cosa under his wing he trusted akka as a
branded criminal to look after her Aqsa
to care of her and fell in love he
proposed and she said yes during this
time he slowly started to see meaning
and living again and even became happy
but then a jealous rival dojo poisoned
his sensei and his fiancée because they
could never beat occas on his sensei in
a fight aqus a lost it and killed 67th
sword
with his bare hands keep in mind this
was before he became a demon Muhsin came
because he heard that there was a demon
in the area only to discover that it was
a human at this point Icaza
understandably didn't care about
anything and let Mouzon turn him into a
demon
thus he didn't really hate the weak he
hated what the world did to his
powerless father and fiance he didn't
actually hate ton judo tundra reminded
him of the sensei he loved it was all an
act he was trying to deny that he kind
of was a good guy at heart even as a
demon he never killed woman even as if
even with his memories erased he stuck
to certain principles knowing this if we
look back at the fight against that end
goku we see that akka had been in want
to kill it and goku he begged him many
times to turn into a demon so he
wouldn't have to die but then goku
couldn't do it because of his own
principles
obviously our casa was a flawed
character who killed many people but
after we compared him to other demons
and after we understand where he came
from it's practically impossible to not
sympathize with the guy he had
everything important to him taken away
from him not once but twice then we
returned to the fight and after alcázar
regains his memories he decides to
self-destruct he could fight on but he
wants to go to the afterlife gracefully
and he's even grateful to tanju his
fiancee's ghost embraces him in our casa
cries begging for forgiveness his
fiancée welcomes him home before his
demon body disappears the fact that his
fiance is welcoming him home after his
sensei said that he cannot go to heaven
implies to me that his fiancee forgoes
her right to go to heaven in order to be
with a casa
just like the Louie's parents did for
their son it's a love story more
touching than Romeo and Juliet for me
and no lie my eyes hurt the water
whenever I reread this part I can only
imagine how emotional it will be when
beautifully animated and with background
music but yeah that's my third spot this
battle had not only epic fighting and
epic new power-ups and redemption it
also managed to take a hated character
and make him one of my favorites
it helped me sympathize my character
that I never thought I would sympathize
with and for all those reasons it will
go down as one of my all-time favorite
fights and demon slayer next in second
place we have the fight against Sonny -
and Kai Goku setting - is another
one of my favorite characters and seeing
his transformation from helpless crybaby
to Opie badass was amazing the
transformations climaxes this fight
where the usually crying comedic relief
character looks extremely serious for
once right from the start of the battle
this fight is an amazing climax for his
audience whose character art he has to
confront his former senpai who was
trained by the same sensei in the breath
of Thunder style this fight is personal
KY God who has become a demon so Sonny
sue has a duty to fight him anyways but
more importantly he needs to stop KY
gaku because of what happened to their
sensei because the student Chi gaku
became a demon 92 cents they committed
seppuku sanicu sensei was the most
important person in his life
you know before Nezu ko came into the
picture his sense he believed in Sonny
too when no one else did even though he
was a huge crybaby that can only learn
one Thunder form for the longest time
Chi gaku doesn't care that the sensei
died kagaku was insulted by the fact
that their sensei wanted to make him and
sunny sue joined under breath successors
he looked down on Sonny sue so much and
he would rather to become a demon than
being lumped in together with Zenit sue
kagaku is much more hateable than a casa
so when Sonny to the underdog gets
revenge it's one of the most satisfying
things ever from the start this guy who
Kakaako views as inferior gets the first
hit I need to even tells kagaku that
he's too slow kai gaku notices like we
do that Sonny too is not only fast but
he's become a completely different
person
Sonny too takes all of kagaku is demon
enhanced thunder breathing attacks and
not only survives but launches a brand
new Opie attack after taking all that
damage it is his own original form a
seventh under breathing form that takes
the form of an electric dragon nature's
attack is so fast like I got Koo a demon
enhanced thunder breather can't even see
it said he too said he wanted to fight
him as an equal with that new form but
he actually surpassed him this kid that
I got who always looked down on
surpassed him without any demon powers
arguably Sonny 2 could have unleashed
this attack even sooner to finish him
off but it seemed like he needed some
more time for closure after this fight
the Sonny 2 gets well enough to attack
moves on along with eNOS key and kana
showing that he wasn't even
hurt in this fight is any two didn't
have to faint to fight
he was cool from start to finish he got
revenge on an extremely hateable
character who made his sensei kill
himself he showcased a new original Opie
form that took the shape of an electric
dragon
he moved too fast for a demon enhanced
thunder breather to see and he killed an
upper moon by himself yes he was an
experienced but he was an upper moon
nonetheless and xeni too became only the
second demon slayer to defeat and upper
moon completely by himself when it comes
to underdog stories and perfectly
executed revenge stories it doesn't get
much better than this however there is
one fight that I would put above it in
first place I have the fight against
upper moon to dolma this to me was one
of the best revenge moments ever
and I even included it in my best
revenge moments in anime video in this
fight three people Gaurav NJ - Kay
Connell and Nobu Shinobu even sacrificed
her life for what became one of the best
twists in the series in order to avenge
her sister who was killed by DOMA
Shinobu started consuming demon poison
over a long period of time she didn't
know if this would have negative effects
on her health but she was willing to
take that risk
she then let the unaware dolma absorb
her into himself as he tended to do with
women at first it seemed like Shinobu
just failed against this ridiculous EOP
demon this guy was so strong his ice
clones could handle a no skin con oh he
didn't even have to fight them himself
when he was about to leave his ice
clones to it that's when - no booze
poison kicked in Kondo now had a chance
to avenge her adoptive sister's kunai
and Shinobu any norske had a chance to
avenge his mother who was killed by
dolma - as with sunny twos fight we get
to see a new cool technique called
Vermillion I during this battle the move
puts so much pressure on Cano's eyes
that it turns them red it pretty much
lets her see things in slow motion and
react quicker the attack could make her
go completely blind but she is willing
to take that risk while he knows Kay
gets captured by a giant ice statue
canal goes in for the kill she gets her
blade into dolmas neck but the cold
makes her too stiff to cut the rotten
neck on her own this is when he knows he
throws his blades from a distance
two canals blade adding the pressure
needed to get dolmas had to come off
thus everyone played a critical role in
getting revenge against this strangely
cheery murder
Shinobu made the ultimate sacrifice and
although it was sad
it was also epic the teamwork came
together perfectly and in the process
they managed to kill one of the
strongest upper moons in Upper Moon way
stronger than kagaku this fight to me is
demon sir at its best and I truly cannot
wait to see it animated and that is it
for today's video thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video and
want to see more like it make sure to
smash that like button to let me know
and share this video if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future and even say your videos and
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]